[Musique]
bonsoir à tous et bienvenue dans votre
émission 7 8 le débat et si l'ensemble
du réseau des transports en commun
devenait gratuit ce scénario mans pour
vous n'est pas ses épaules et éthiques
depuis qu'en mars dernier la mairie de
paris puis la région ile-de-france ont
mandaté des experts pour étudier les
modalités de sa mise en place
si valérie pécresse le président de
région refuse de diminuer le budget du
transport
il faudra bien trouver ailleurs ces
trois milliards d'euros générés par la
vente des pass navigo et des tickets si
pour l'instant rien n'a été décidé cette
éventualité suscite de nombreuses
questions
en cas d'instauration de la gratuité qui
devra payer l'addition quels seraient
les impacts escompté sur cette gratuité
est ce une utopie qui se concrétisera
simple coup de com entre deux entités
politiques rivales pour débattre de ces
questions j'accueille autour de moi
galles barbotin conseiller régional
l'est républicain des yvelines mais
également clément ortega pelletier
secrétaire de section du parti
communiste de l'art derrière mais
également ancien conseiller régional
bonsoir à vous et merci d'avoir accepté
notre invitation
alors la gratuité pour les usagers du
transport un coût 3 8 milliards d'euros
c'est la deuxième source de financement
du transport après les employeurs mais
avant les subventions publiques
alors votre parti est traditionnellement
ceux dits pro business ne veut pas
augmenter la fiscalité sur les
entreprises ni des impôts sur les
ménages
est-ce que c'est pas davantage de
l'affichage qu'une véritable volonté
politique d'instaurer cette gratuité des
transports dont je pense qu'il ya une
véritable alors suite elle à la
déclaration d'anne hidalgo ce 19 mars
chocraux agonise
bien évidemment afficher gérait d'emblée
cette volonté d'une gratuité pour les
parisiens pourquoi pas c'est madame le
maire de paris qui à un moment donné
cherche à faire de l'affichage
préalablement gerald quelque part où
aller aux élections qui se profilent en
tout cas moi je le perçois de cette
manière là on est vraiment à ce niveau
là dans l'affichage ce qui a été mis en
avant c'est avant tout l'idée qu'il
fallait dépolluer l'air de paris et donc
des polluants l'air de paris il fallait
rendre accessible à tous dans toutes
circonstances les transports parisiens
pour les parisiens et la grande question
qui se pose c'est que pour la région ile
de france bien évidemment mon travail
par l'échelle de paris on travaille à
l'échelle de l'île de france avec des
publics différents qui ont des attentes
différentes qui ont des besoins
complètement spécifique en soit en zone
rurale le construire en zones urbaines
et à partir de là bien évidemment les
choses sont pas aussi simple que ça on
n'arrive pas en dix ans d'un coup de
baguette magique demain on enlève le
prix du pass navigo à 75 euros 27
commissaires barrage année d'algos la
gratuité pas du tout pas du tout la
question mérite d'être posée quand une
question mérite d'être posée faut avoir
des réponses qui soient pertinentes
à partir du moment où on fait le choix
d'avoir des transports qu'ils soient
qu'ils soient opérationnels qu'ils
soient performants qu'ils soient
réadapter je dirais aux besoins actuels
des franciliens nécessairement il y a un
coût dans la mise en oeuvre il ya un
goût dans leurs exploitations donc
investissement et fonctionnement à
partir de là il faut pouvoir trouver le
moyen de financer s'est installé hier
que cette possible ça veut dire que la
question se pose c'est effectivement
possible mais ça n'est pas né ce n'est
pas la voie exclusive vers laquelle
aujourd'hui en tout cas nous nous avons
s'interroge on se dit c'est possible
est-ce que c'est pertinent oui non
pourquoi dans quelles circonstances est
ce qu'il faut aller plus loin dans une
démarche que de de gratuité il faut
savoir que vous lui disiez tout à
l'heure 3 milliard et 2 milliards 8 on
va vous revenir notamment sur la manière
de financer
d'abord on va revenir 7 à l'heure mais
tout d'abord est ce que justement ce
débat sur la gratuité c'est pas une
victoire des idées communistes les parts
bout même très fortement c'est ce qui
est intéressant est depuis des dizaines
d'années sur la question de la gratuité
des transports en ile de france
ces mêmes c'est même pour cela que l'on
porte depuis d'élection en élection d
des campagnes qui sont sur l'extension
des tarification sociale que ce soit
pour les chômeurs pour les moins de 18
ans on demande même la gratuité pour les
moins de 18 ans c'est pour cela que on
s'est battu et on a gagné la carte
imagine r à l'époque pour les étudiants
et pour les lycéens dont une autre
stratégie c'était de gagner au fur et à
mesure l'extension des tarification
sociale avec même comme comme point
d'orgue la question d'une zone unique
pour l'ensemble de l'ile-de-france parce
que on parle de l'accès à tous aux
transports mais c'est effectivement à
tous y compris ceux qui sont à
l'intérieur de paris les parisiens mais
aussi ceux qui sont en moyenne
et puis en grande couronne ce qui nous
concerne pour ce qui est des yvelines
donc nous on porte ça depuis des
dizaines d'années dont les voeux vous
croyez notamment la sincérité jamais à
paris et surtout de la région
ile-de-france de vraiment s'intéresser à
la question je vous avoue que moi je
suis un peu j'ai été un peu étonné parce
que j'étais pendant un mandat conseiller
régional et à chaque fois que nous
abordions la question de la tarification
sociale
la majorité socialiste et était
extrêmement frileuses il a fallu
batailler deux commissions commission de
discussions de couloir en discussions de
couloir parfois on y allait même un peu
au culot lord lors de l'assemblée du
conseil régional ont disons là il faut
avancer sur les sur les handicapés sur
l'irl arrêté sur cette visite royale au
passage facile notamment que la droite
serait alors là moi je suis étonné de la
part de madame hidalgo je le suis encore
plus de la part de la présidente du
conseil régional parce que c'est d'une
incohérence
hallucinante pendant la campagne valérie
pécresse fait campagne en disant je ne
toucherai pas au prix du pass navigo
depuis qu'elle est et vu le pass navigo
à prix 5 euros
on parle même d'une augmentation 10
euros pour l'année prochaine je trouve
que là on est dans une incohérence et
tout d'un coup elle se porte comme we
regardons la gratuité c'est une bonne
idée
oui alors c'est une réponse déjà par
rapport au prix du pass navigo générer
quelque part quand nous sommes arrivés
suite à l'élection
donc il ya maintenant un peu plus de
deux ans on s'est aperçu que il y avait
eu j'ai pas parlé dissimulation en tout
cas il y avait dans les comptes qui
prenait qui intégrait justement les
transports et un déficit d'environ 300
un peu plus de 300 millions d'euros
qu'il fallait nécessairement financer
alors pour le financer évidemment
comment est-ce qu'on procède gérer c'est
pas le tout à un moment donné de faire
des investissements de se dire que ces
investissements seront financés par la
dette seront financées par l'emprunt
vous savez aujourd'hui comme moi qu'à un
moment donné la saine gestion va
impliquer un regard particulier sur le
niveau d'endettement des structures de
cette nature pour faire en sorte que
justement on soit dans une recherche
d'équilibré budgétaire
ce que l'on ne paye pas aujourd'hui on
le paye demain si on le fait au travers
de 2017 mais ça encore une facette
importante pour revenir pour venir
notamment à notre débat de ce soir qui
est vraiment et gratuité des transports
je trouve la question c'est qui va payer
aujourd'hui quelles questions
différentes solutions juju juste avant
il ya une question c'est qu'on se pose
pas c'est est-ce que c'est utile et
pourquoi c'est utile pourquoi nous
communistes on le porte depuis des
dizaines d'années mais c'est pas
uniquement parce que on est pour la
gratuité pour tous et on nie pas pour la
gratuité pour tous mais sur la question
du transport
on le porte très fortement pour skill
l'île de france parce que sur des
questions environnementales
ces dunes et extrêmement limpides n'y a
pas besoin de faire une longue
explication démontré que quand même plus
on utilise les transports en commun - on
pollue sauf qu'on est dans une politique
portée par la droite notamment que les
effets des lois qu'ils sont quand même
vraiment énormément motorisés sur avait
beaucoup de voitures vont abandonner
leur voiture pour un transport en commun
ça c'est vraiment je prends et je crois
que le maillage du transport en commun
dans les yvelines n'est pas bon on a
investi énormément surtout tangentielle
qui n'est pas très utilisé on regarde
pas réellement comment rattraper ce
triangle je veux dire allez de
rambouillet amante d'aller de
saint-quentin aux mureaux traverser ce
triangle est extrêmement compliqué or on
le sait la majorité des yvelinois se
transporte dans les yvelines ce qui
était d'ailleurs un vrai débat sur la
question du paris du grand paris express
c'est que en réalité les yvelinois
utilisent leur voiture pour rester dans
les mines donc le transport en commun
quels qu'ils soient et le maillage est
pas vrai il ya même il ya même des
exigences que l'on porte depuis des
années et qui ne sont toujours pas
toujours pas porté
on parle de la ligne du rer qui nous on
ne porte pour aller jusqu à rambouillet
et qui serait une vraie solution pendant
un certains nombres de rambolitains pour
aller à saint quentin en yvelines
on demande à ce que la ligne ter
visage qu'est-ce que vous entrez jetant
dans la gratuité des transports pourquoi
ce serait une bonne chose
la question de la gratuité se pose ce
que je sais du trader la question
d'ailleurs elle sait se pose justement
peut-être pour favoriser l'accès de
certains publics
jusqu'où est ce qu'on met la barre par
rapport aux certain public est ce qu'on
reste sur les limites qui sont
aujourd'hui définies qui sont les
publics ont tiré en précarité et qui
sont certains publics recherche d'emploi
depuis 17 heures mais à partir de là la
question pourquoi pas augmenter le
niveau de l'eau niveau d'accessibilité à
cette gratuité donc c'est pour ça qui
est important aujourd'hui d'avoir une
étude moi je le considère alors il ya ce
que moi je peux penser mais il ya en
même temps c'est tout ce que je disais
tout à l'heure ce qui peut être
pertinente je dirais à poser comme
projet social qui se dégrade et des
propositions qui ont été faites entre
autres tarification sociale pour les
handicapés pour les retraités qui ont
été présentées en décembre lors du
conseil régional votre groupe lui même
que vous avez voté contre
donc je veux bien entendre tout d'un
coup nous voulons nous voulons étudier
la question sauf que dans la réalité
lorsque l'on vous fait des propositions
eh ben on se retrouve toujours face à un
mur ce qui était déjà le cas de valérie
pécresse
on en revient là encore à ce que nous
avons pris à un moment donné il ya deux
ans nous avons récupéré un réseau ferré
et un réseau de transports en commun qui
était totalement délabrée pu me dire les
choses comme elles sont un réseau qui
était délabrée dans lequel il y avait
les sous-investissements par lequel on
se retrouvait avec une derrière une un
nuage avec de la fraude avec il a fallu
moderniser l'ensemble du réseau
on est actuellement dans ce processus
c'est évidemment ça coûte
à un moment donné la question se pose et
c'est là où ça va être important
la question se pose de savoir qui paye
aujourd'hui où vous l'avez dit vous avez
au niveau des entreprises vous avez donc
les transports le transport qui est
financé par des entreprises qui est
financé par les collectivités locales
territoriales qui est financé en même
temps je dirais par des contributions
externes
j'en ai sur un budget de 10 milliards
les 10 milliards la question elle est la
question elle est sur les 10 milliards
si on retire 3 milliards se taire un
tiers du montant global
ben nécessairement il ya deux hypothèses
la première c'est soit on trouve de quoi
compenser ces trois milliards qui
manqueraient soit on se retrouve dans la
situation on dégrade le service à
hauteur des trois milliards d'euros
même le choix la fascination qu'elle
s'élève à sélestat n'ont pas le choix
ils effet préservé à hauteur de 10
milliards le montant n'a fait des
investissements et donc ce serait de
passer à la gratuité dans ce cas là mais
non c'est de trouver les financements
qui vont bien au jargon n'a pas la
solution
aujourd'hui on n'a pas la solution
collège d'experts aujourd'hui on n'a pas
la solution on cherche à ce que c'est là
où effectivement je réponds à la
question qui est que cela je trouve que
constituer une commission c'est
effectivement surtout ne pas chercher à
y répondre et je ne crois pas que
valérie pécresse est lancé l'idée de
cette commission en disant je veux
vraiment qu'on y trouve les solutions
parce que trouver des solutions ça fait
des années qu'on y porte
ça fait des années corse quand on dit il
faut augmenter le versement transport
c'est à dire la contribution des déserts
des listes d'entreprises non c'est pas
pénalisé non non non l'utilisation des
transports en commun et d'augmenter ses
capacités
c'est favoriser des entreprises et vous
le savez très bien pour le développement
économique
il faut des véritables transport
brassard est efficace c'est déjà la fin
de cette émission mais ça vous beaucoup
d'y avoir participé
quant à vous je vous invite à revoir
cette émission sur notre site internet
et à la partager sur les réseaux sociaux
je vous souhaite de passer une agréable
soirée et à d'ici deux semaines alors va
[Musique]